fitness entrepreneurs are my favorite
let me tell you why they're so good at
their craft but then with the business
they don't do the thing they do in
fitness fitness entrepreneurs [ __ ] on
people because people want shortcuts in
fitness they want all sorts of [ __ ]
when the answer is put the work in the
gym and eat properly like follow the
model but then as entrepreneurs you see
these [ __ ] all beefed up did
everything [ __ ] perfect i'm talking
about the ones that don't cheat i'm
talking about doing it right
and then they come to business and
they're like what's the shortcut and i'm
like you know that there's no shortcut
in this [ __ ]
the [ __ ] are you looking for shortcut in
this show i'm fascinated by how few
people win in quick moves yet the
majority of people are looking for it
there is no system there is no passive
income framework there is lunch pail and
hard hat day in and day out grinding and
trying to bring value to the people that
you're trying to sell something to